he jumps up you won't sell like neva you
want some - all right no ladies and
gentlemen please give it up bad scratch
on the first one yeah I got a ask you so
you your guy who grows up in the New
Orleans area it feels like you were born
to play football why did you choose
Miami
y'all moment want to stand up and look
and say why not land by those stairs I
wanted to win the national championship
and thank God we did you know I actually
got my ring on right here you know so
that was about to me man I was about
playing playing at the highest level but
put myself in position to also make it
to the NFL you know I was a businessman
at a young age man just a little touch
what was it like being the man on campus
and the man in Miami we parted after the
game we can get you do whatever you want
after the game but that week man just
chill out I got to ask you about one
specific moment word on the street is
you and Shannon Briggs whoa whoa whoa
had a little something-something that
happen what happened that night the
night in the class of 94 in class the 97
class the 95 was known as to jeez cuz
they're graduating mm so it's me and
Brian McKinney
Brian McKinney and I youngest ones with
them hanging out and we're on the beach
win the club and one of the older guys
come back in like you don't have it come
on let's go let's go
um when our teammates just got knocked
out like knocked out you can kind of
fight let's go so we're like all right
as we coming through I'm actually in the
front so I'm looking like so what's up
man like why y'all jumped on our boy
well you know why you knocked him out
and lo and behold he jumps up you won't
so like Devo you want some - all right
no whoo Shannon Briggs man
seven Braves as a boxer yeah yeah a
champion boxer very leet box how big we
talk to you man Shannon Shannon freeze I
mean when he stood up he looked like
King Kong but he's huge
solid too but I got a bunch of cash with
me so Ryan McKinney come through by
McKinney is like six nine 300 something
at this time needless to say Brian
McKinney didn't give up a sack in Miami
so Brian McKinney comes through wait
wait wait get the he was like get the
little guy so there's two of them I come
around whatever hit the little guy he's
pretty much out of there Brian
grab Shannon Briggs by his dreads yanked
him down like he's the white Freni he's
on the ground man and they just stay
Welling on him now I mean they're going
to town on him right and he's just on
the ground on his all forces taking it
so I go over to bout time I get over
there man this guy's just took off
running out of the group
he's getting kicked all kinds of stuff
right so we go back in the club like man
I'm done ready to go home now then we
got to find our boy doe so we finally
getting we're on we're like Collins and
17 so how far is that from here right
from this location wearing myself betray
we are 17 right now right this is 17 we
like right here and he's at Nikki Beach
Nikki Beach is ocean and one ocean
aversion you like that quick you ran
down there dude you know so that mean
that's kind of high hat man that next
day dude we had practice we were walking
out there sore like we got in a boxing
fight we didn't know that it was Shannon
Briggs at the time you know I'm setting
until he actually got soothed by my boy
cuz he broke his jaw you know you can't
boxers can't fight on the street there's
a weapon you
so you wind up getting sued and
everything you know I'm saying so so
neither so you cool what standard Briggs
now what's the relation thanks for
kicking it with us subscribe to be our
to check out more dope videos like this
one